35 days away from the general election  I'm Minister bacon I jujitsu than the  right thing I get Nigel Farage looking  pretty good and I'm pleased at least  there is a debate it's happening we've  got a chance to have a proper discussion  and i hope the true comes out well I  value about that opportunity to support  directly gripper nice people politics in  fragmented to party leaders who don't  seem to woken up to the fact our Ed  Miliband and David Cameron David Cameron  or probably at Miliband and Clegg Nigel  couch and then three others what I'm  focused on is getting across a positive  message and I think tonight if we see a  situation when people try and make a  personal photos will make a judgment on  that sorry I'm afraid I've got a little  bit it took time right  adidas a moment of great opportunity I  relish the opportunity 35 days away from  the general election 35 days too many  for some of you